where does germany stand 25 years after reunification
i would like to
talk to holger schmieding
chief economist grund bank economist
in our studio today thank you very much for being
here now this solidarity pact 2
is due to expire in 2019 i
have heard that
everything is not as it should be  should be
what happens then i think that
we don't
really need a new solidarity pact what we of course
need is the usual
financial equalization of the federal states we need a
targeted regional policy it has to be further
promoted
but it doesn't have to be promoted everywhere with a watering
can you have to
specifically target the remaining ones
tackling problems and of course saying so
overall we have already achieved a great
deal in the last 25 years
how much have we achieved where
is the whole of germany 25 years
after reunification
it hasn't always been easy in the last
25 years but today the
whole of germany is doing extremely well because
we  have  actually full employment
a balanced national budget
no inflation
we are so popular in the world that
maybe more people
want to come to us than we would like
that is in a certain sense also a
hidden compliment of course germany has
problems but in
international comparison it is
doing extremely well today then  of course i have to be
angry and take the
wind out of your sails a little bit
at least you could also say
germany was doing well because at the moment
germany is confronted with many many problems
you have already said we
are popular in the world that alone is
not the reason for the flow of refugees,
which is now also leading to a political
crisis they say german
germany is popular now the
german products have come under criticism a
bit thanks to the scandals that
surround us and the euro
will not save much but the problem
is  not solved yet  st how
do you keep track of
course the situation is confusing but
that's a typical way of life
when we look at the big trends
then we see that the german
economy is running quite
reasonably we see that above all
more and more jobs are on the
ground here  that our
incomes will rise that the gap between
rich and poor will not widen any
further, but that i is slowly
closing the developments are
mostly going in the right direction
, however, we have major challenges
ahead of us, first of all, we have to now that we
are apparently getting additional workers
from the refugees  make our
labor market even more flexible
we have to make sure that we have
the right living space and of
course we have
to control immigration as much as possible so
that above all
we get the people we need who are well
trained and that we
probably have fewer people overall  get refugees
than is the case at the moment
the problems are there but again in an
international comparison and